this toggle right here this is 40
million dollars right here when a lot of
these things are being seen by say
commercial military Pilots the cameras
they have are not designed for this your
camera on a military plane is designed
to pick up enemy threats it's not
designed to have very clean images so
these military jets should have science
mode right you flick a button and then
it goes into curiosity why not equip
these planes with with better cameras
together this day to have the cameras
they currently have or put a second
camera on they give them an iPhone 6
that would be better it's only got two
gigs of two gigs but iPhone 6 could take
better images than anything they've been
showing us hey if you don't have
military spending works you add an
iPhone 6 to an F-16 that's going to be
like 20 million dollars on the contract
and a special cable right you're gonna
have to
million dollars right here